[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
l'influencent des cabinets de conseil un
phénomène tentaculaire
accenture capgemini
mckinsey
au quotidien des cabinets privés conseil
l'état dans sa stratégie son
organisation et ses infrastructures
informatiques
l' expertise de ces cabinets a ainsi été
sollicités sur la plupart des grandes
réformes du quinquennat et lors de la
crise de l'aco vide
cette pratique soulève deux questions la
souveraineté de l'état face à des
organismes privés d'une part et la bonne
utilisation des deniers publics d'autre
part
pour y voir plus clair le sénat avait
créé en novembre dernier une commission
d' enquête relative à l'influencé
croissante de ces cabinets de conseil
sur les politiques publiques
arnaud bazin en était le président et
eliane assassi la rapporteure
le 17 mars 2022 celle ci a rendu
publiques ses conclusions
le rapport révèle que les dépenses de
conseils de l'état ont dépassé le
milliard d'euros en 2021
entre 2018 et 2021 les dépenses de
conseils des ministères ont plus que
doublé
la commission d' enquête indique que les
livrables des consultants sollicité ne
donne pas toujours satisfaction
or une journée de consultants coûte en
moyenne 1500 28 euros à l'état
la commission denquête a pu mesurer
également le degré d' influence de ces
cabinets privés sur les prises de
décision au sein des ministères
leur rôle consiste à proposer des
scénarios arbitrable mais ceux ci sont
le plus souvent orientés
cette priorisation des scénarios par les
cabinets de conseils réduit d'autant
plus la marge de manoeuvre des
responsables publics
concernant l'opacité qui entoure souvent
ses prestations de conseil la commission
denquête recommande notamment qu'elle
soit présentée dans le bilan social
unique pour permettre représentants des
agents publics d'en débattre
pour mieux encadrer et limiter le
recours à ces organismes privés elle se
prononce en outre en faveur d'une
évaluation systématique des prestations
de conseil et plaident aussi pour
l'élaboration d'un plan de
réinternaliser ation des compétences au
sein des ministères
parallèlement il convient selon la
commission de renforcer les règles
déontologiques des cabinets de conseil
en imposant une déclaration d'intérêts
aux consultants afin que
l'administration puisse prévenir les
risques de conflits d'intérêts
cette déclaration serait contrôlé par la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]